hi my name is Jeremy Sikes I'll be doing
a talk on Wolfram media and book tools I
work for Wolfram research and I am a
publishing assistant
all right well welcome to the Wolfram
media presentation for anybody who was
here last year obviously Andre was
running it then and he's here to make
sure I don't get anything wrong so what
are we doing with all four media what
does it mean why are we publishing under
this
okay I am Jeremy Sikes
I am the publishing assistant
effectively I am the project manager for
Wolfram media animal for me related
things that we do and that is mostly
publications but it also includes some
legal issues and also some author
relations so essentially what we want to
do here is to promote the use of the
Wolfram language that is what we're
looking for when we consider submissions
I'll get into a little bit that about
that later we also publish Stephens
books of course and that's in large part
because we have an attention to detail
that suits exactly what Stephen wants so
it's it has worked well for as a
partnership there one thing I want to
highlight here and we'll get into this
more is that the more you can bring to
us in terms of your abilities to code
the more we can give back we have lots
of resources that the company can offer
but development strength is reserved for
development and research and R&D here so
that that is one thing that I wanted to
get out there right now all right so
just to give an idea from from Stephens
perspective he's working on a variety of
books they're all under wraps we want to
make sure that you know he's got
complete freedom to play around he will
be publishing a series of small smaller
epubs through this year and also his
book from earlier the second edition for
a iwl was published in 2017 that's
elementary introduction to the Wolfram
language and we are we had it translated
to Chinese last year this year into
Korean that that is set for publication
maybe by the end of the year probably
January of 2018
we also are
having it in Japanese Spanish and
Indonesia nose or all deals in the works
so yeah excited exciting things for
translations in Stephen Wolfram so yes
okay yeah can you guys can you guys see
all right so we've got a few projects
that we are working on right now one of
them is programming the Raspberry Pi
with the Wolfram language any of you
probably saw Ian Johnson's presentation
downstairs and his presentation but he's
got a couple of computers and PI's set
up and he's been working with them he is
working with us as a technical reviewer
for this book and helping us get through
it I think it'll be exciting thing one
of the things I really hope to do is to
promote this book to the maker community
which is really growing in strength so I
and I think a lot of the maker community
knows that that the PI comes with the
ability to use the Wolfram language but
I think a lot of people still are not
using it and that's one of the main
reasons for this book we want to change
that and then of course we have an
author in the room with us right now
that's Barry Dayton I'm gonna take a
quick departure from my outline here
because he has to run I'll show you what
what he's been up to you probably if you
went to his talk earlier you may have
seen some of his is fascinating curves
so yeah that's going to be a book for
programming algebraic curves in the
Wolfram language that is obviously what
we're focusing on here is is teaching
the code even when it's really advanced
and that's what this is for we'll get
into the forms of publication later
we've we have a couple of different
options the last one is the science of
casino blackjack by Richard word hammer
and this is something that we will be
publishing on Wolfram cloud this is not
his book his book is actually by
published by Springer so we're doing
this in partnership with Springer which
is another thing that we'll touch upon
we do partnerships with other publishing
entities and we have favorable relations
with most of them so this is a very
exciting thing the Wolfram cloud
obviously we made a huge leap forward in
2017 and next year we'll have another
major release as well so I'll show you
that in a little bit well actually I
guess I can show that to you right now
this hasn't been through our design or
through our UX
centers yet this is literally just as
sort of a sample of and Springer doesn't
give anything like this right they're
not even capable of this there they you
can download a notebook from the
Springer site so this is all really new
to them and and and really exciting in
the publishing world if we can get it to
work well so you've got a navigation bar
here and then you know some information
about the the chapter in which this is
and then you've got a working
manipulable
this is a fairly fairly simple one
obviously a lot of the stuff that you
guys are going to be working with or
it's a lot more complicated this is
something that is still in development
and we hope to see some exciting things
next year as well alright and just to go
through here I'm not going to read them
all but you'll see there are a number of
publications that where we you know
we've chatted with people about that we
friend are very exciting and and you can
see that we're looking at books that are
very much subject related but you know
the it has to be a book that's about the
code and about the Wolfram language for
us to for us to publish it you know we
do have two different speeds of
publishing as well if we're printing a
book we're spending money to print it
we're putting real skin in the game if
we're publishing a P you know to print
on Kindle that we have a lot more
flexibility with and and and barry
Dayton's book which is a highly
complicated book about about algebraic
curves fits more in the in the latter
half we're not printing his book we are
making a print what we call a print
replica and that's Anna's on speak for a
fixed layout you know something that you
you can take your your iPad or your
Amazon fire your Kindle Fire and you
just page through and it and it looks
pretty good yes I do yeah I'll let him
get out of here cuz I know he's got
yep yeah just meet with me after I will
I will get your information it's a
simple installer file and the nice thing
about it is that you know we're
constantly updating and all you need to
do is just rerun it periodically you'll
get the latest updates it will you know
take out the old palette and put in the
new palette I have a demonstration of it
up here as well alright so in terms of
how we publish obviously print this is
something that you know I've had a lot
of conversations with various authors
since the conference started and some
people are very excited to still print
books some people aren't all that
interested in it
some people want something that's
completely free some people want
something that's out there in the world
that you know people can buy we in print
in color and one of the reasons that we
can do that is that a lot of our
software I don't need to tell you guys
this is deals with color and to not to
not be able to print in color you would
lose a lot of of what the the message is
so it's it's not an issue for us we're
not doing it for every text but you know
for anybody who can make a a pretty good
appeal I don't think that's really an
issue you know publishing is not our
primary objective here our primary
objective here is showing this off
during the best light so that that's
certainly something we can talk about I
mentioned earlier that we do fixed
layout epub for anybody who's read with
a Kindle you know you know you can
usually you know we realized the text
every time you zoom in and whatnot
we don't do that in large part because
it's not even images which are a problem
it's mostly math it's mostly displaying
code in a way that makes sense so we
don't do that we do fixed layout PDFs at
some point we might you know shipped
over and certainly for other books like
we did Stephens idea makers that was in
a standard epub file so we are capable
of it we prefer the fixed layout because
that way we can show
things exactly the way we want to show
them so we do also in various
circumstances people can sell notebooks
from the wolfram store there we do have
one author who supplements his
coursework every year with notebooks
that he runs specifically for his class
and he gets his class to get them so
that's something we support also I'm
sure you've all seen I didn't actually
preload it but I'm sure you've all seen
a Stephens book online that's something
that we are also offering we haven't had
an opportunity to do it yet and so we
might run into some issues there but for
the most part it should be pretty easy
to create that page and run with it
obviously yeah
yeah and the way we've done that in the
past is we've had a delayed release
sometimes for for that and that's the
way it's worked in some of the contracts
that we've worked on but yeah you know
that is a real draw for for people is to
have a site like like Steven does so
just some of the you know the publishing
details I don't know if we'd be really
interested in this stuff
our main distributors Ingram Ingram is
the the biggest distributor in the world
so you know we have a couple of others
and we certainly use Amazon because that
is the way a lot of people access the
market obviously but yeah we we have
lots of different ways to to access the
market and Ingram is probably for print
sales the best way to do that moving on
so just to give you an idea of how the
process works Berry knows this because
he's dealt with it for a long time
usually the intake process starts with
talking to me and you know either by
email or by or by at the conference or
what-have-you sometimes I get people
from sales talk contacting me saying oh
you know this one of our clients really
wants to write a book on blank and
that's how that conversation gets
started at that point you know I'll
solicit submission materials from you
and it will go through a technical
review one of the main things that we
really want to highlight is that you
know the state of the art you know
coding is is happening on-site here and
if we know something that you don't
we're going to want you to show that and
they're always in some sometimes things
like like 11.2 offers some some new
things that are still kind of in process
so sometimes we won't use those things
sometimes we will we're basically happy
with the code if it works but our our
technical reviewers will we'll make it
the best code that we can do there will
also be a scientific review it's not an
in-depth review it's not like you know
publishing with Woodspring or it would
be go out to anonymous reviewers or
anything we use our and our internal
staff we have people and basically every
aspect of that you would be publishing
and so
that's not a problem in terms of
production this is all nitty-gritty
stuff if you're interested or not we
generally have two sets of notebooks
that we start with there's the the
source notebook that you originally sent
to us we get that in this the style that
we want and then we create the print
source notebook obviously books have
very specific pages we don't want to
mess with things you know you want every
page to have the exact right material on
it one thing I wanted a caution anybody
who's interested in submitting to us
though we do break things up a little
bit we like shorter blocks of code not
you know we like one-liners too in terms
of code so that's one thing that we'll
be doing with your print source
notebooks is that we'll be getting them
really ready to to publish on an actual
page and the main reason for that even
if we don't publish your book in print
and this is what we did with Barry's
book is that when we publish it to the
Kindle it will be a fixed layout as if
it could be printed and one of the nice
things about Amazon is that you could
simply want if you want to buy a book
and have it printed they'll do it and
they haven't have print-on-demand that
is pretty pretty decent quality we're
going to prep your best chapters first
and once they're in in the best best way
that they can be we'll do a final review
and then offer a contract so how do we
promote our books sure you've probably
seen some of our our social media we and
you know we've got dozens of websites
that do this for hands-on start I
interviewed the authors of the book and
we posted a blog on the RAI blog and I
Wolfram blog excuse me and we have
Twitter accounts we have LinkedIn
accounts Facebook accounts you know
we've got all that stuff so but you know
these are just some of the ways that
we'll do it one of the things that I'll
be doing in production is I'll be
researching your the market for your
book and trying to build a base where I
can I can do that we do have also a
dozen mailing lists which we may or may
not use Ingram also you have to pay for
these promotions but they are generally
successful this is what they do and they
do it well so or we are willing to do
that as well
then of course industry-specific you're
all academics you all go to conferences
if it's not something you want to deal
with just tell me I'll get in touch with
the conference producer and make sure
your book is there generally that's
pretty easy to do so one thing that's
written into every contract that we have
is product updates you guys know our
software changes pretty quickly so we'll
you'll want it to be updated and we do -
and you know that it might take a little
bit of time to get things sorted but
that we are interested in doing that we
want your work to last alright so for a
basic submission you know get in contact
with me I would like a CV a book
proposal and a you know a table of
contents and to chapter notebooks I
would like a chapter notebook that has a
code and has graphics these are going to
be the show pieces that we that we start
with and that we try to get into good
working order as quickly as possible
so one one thing I get asked a lot is do
we accept low tech submissions latex
submissions we do not it's more trouble
than it's worth
and we're about publishing in notebooks
that's one of the main things that I do
is trying to push notebooks into the
publishing world so that's what we do
and that's what you'll have to submit as
so yeah so what are we interested in
right now we've got the markets pretty
saturated with calculus notebooks which
isn't to say calculus books books it
isn't to say we wouldn't you know
countenance it but we are looking for
things that show our code in different
areas engineering and in social research
you've all heard so many of the great
natural language things that we can do
so we really want to get that coding
into the hands of people who wouldn't
normally use it so any an e-book idea
that you have that can focus on that is
automatically going to receive a little
bit more attention
using the Wolfram language to make as I
talked about the the whole makerfaire
concept earlier this is this is a big
deal right now and it's really easy to
use the Wolfram language to do that so
that that's something that was going to
really push things forward one thing
that I will say is that you have to make
sure that the your proposal is focusing
on teaching the Wolfram language the
science is is what we want to see how
you do your science with the Wolfram
language so you're not hiding your code
you're showing your code and to the
extent that you have to you know change
things around a little bit that might be
something that we would we would really
push for and we are flexible but that's
that's sort of what we're going for so I
did create a little right so one of the
things that I will send to you is the
the Wolfram book tools palette this is
what it looks like
and you know yeah I'll explain those
right so this is this is the Wolfram
book tools palette and when you start
when you when you install it you know
and and you start with another notebook
let's see you would go to palette I mean
you guys know this stuff but once it's
installed it will automatically list
down here as one of the options that
will bring up this and then you click
new section that's where you start your
book and unfortunately at this point you
really if you've got your book already
written you're going to have to put it
into this format if you want to design a
conversion tool I am more than happy to
distribute it we haven't done it yet we
will but it will take some time so just
to give you an idea of how the how this
you how this works
these this tool is this palette part is
more to bring these things up and also
to link you can link between between
notebooks we prefer that each chapter is
its own notebook that's how we'll that's
how we'll be working on it and we'll
just break it apart if you don't so
might as well do it that way
you see under here section subsection
there is actually a sub sub section and
the button here isn't isn't quite ready
yeah
yeah yeah
right and you know there are a couple of
sort of sort of interesting things that
we encourage you to explore and to think
about these are these are sort of
textbook things that we've reused in a
iwl and they're great ways to end
chapters it's supposed to sort of banal
summaries no if this is all this is all
tech specific if you're if your book
doesn't need it
then don't use it you can also you know
if you wanted to say have a reference
section you would literally just go in
here and and do your so and and we're
willing to be flexible about that one
thing that you can do is so you know
that's a function so that's not what was
supposed to happen yeah so then you go
up here you click inline code
yeah worked before anyways it worked
with this one I think you know what I
think it is is just it made it the whole
link instead of this plus because I
started at the end of the cell so
language
that said as long as your
yes as our language at the bow
you know there are folks who
yeah
hey but I've had it had the sub
subsection added since we spoke this
morning
yeah oh so that I I will send you the
Installer and then you just reload the
Installer you know periodically animal
yeah sure yeah we're just not responding
yeah
so that whole thing there that says
doctor to installer you know I got tired
of
all right well I don't have too much
more but one thing I will say is that
part of my job for those of you who are
just publishing a book is to help you
interface with your publisher so you
know if you have an editor you know an
acquisitions editor that wants you to
submit in a certain way or is having a
problem with how something is looking
when you come talk to me and I can get
you the expertise to fix the problem for
your publisher so yeah
alexxa published my book
[Laughter]
yeah as much as
for those of you who just are a little
bit late I just wanted to bring up the
Wolfram cloud example again it says this
has not been through our design team at
all or even the UX team this is just
something I put together which impressed
the hell out of Springer
so obviously what we'll do is a lot
better than that
yeah
absolutely I mean that's why it's our
like I don't have it open but let's go
ahead and open Stephens book
yeah yeah we we also have the wool from
you I don't know if that would that's
that's that that would be not part of
your school's thing but you know you
could offer materials through the wool
from you when that's official officially
launched
but if you were to say just publish your
book and we were to put it up on a site
somewhat like this you know that all
that content was would be free right
there one of the one of the things that
I looked at yesterday was somebody had
purchased a private cloud license and it
actually put a fully manipulatable
courseware tool together on his own
private cloud you know it waits it
doesn't handle all the manipulates as
well as we'd like it's still you know
work in progress in terms of speed
particularly anything that uses an solve
or it's continuously recalculating along
a curve that's a little bit a strenuous
use of the product but for you know to
simply change a number an equation and
then evaluate it it does that so that's
not a problem come on up Andre I mean we
could talk about some typesetting tricks
and all that and this other pallet but I
can well well while Andre is walking up
here I will just show this other poem
right well I guess your and you're kind
of saying that
why not the continent
yeah yeah we are certainly looking at
that's not your normal laptop I told
them about sorry
yeah yeah well actually since so the
first edition that's what we wanted the
second edition does use some syntax
color right
so that they left they left all the
syntax comment and we felt like I mean I
think for the very beginner type of
project
maybe that's alright but it becomes a
bit easily extracted particularly you
know when you're alright so what I
didn't get a chance to show earlier
today you know notebooks are being
understood as a thing 2530 years after
we kind of brought them out and and
we're you know the other folks in the
world using them promoting them arguing
that's a baby you know but we had
avoided trying to promote our technology
under the notebook banner for quite a
while using CDF instead
but we kind of feel like now avoid that
and so the conversation will become a
little bit more about notebook steam the
standard thing you have to be more about
the enterprise conversation but anyway I
just want to show that because the
if it was publicly available I could
show but so you know so some of these P
be really responsive and pretty decent
and you know Jeremy was showing Richard
worth intern project which we were using
as an example because he already has a
publisher to kind of talk to the
publisher and say hey user cloud user
cloud this stuff is better similarly you
know we want to do the same thing for
demonstration so Steven showing the home
page he didn't actually go to
demonstrations but you know the idea is
that we have animated gifs overlay as a
preview we didn't quite get the
sequencing done right here but you saw
that load after that blue line went
across that's that was loading from the
cloud that should have been happening
behind the animation right and so that
when the animation is done that the
thing is ranked they are ready to use
you know you're ready to play with it so
you know it's still getting polished you
saw it jump a little bit because the the
animation and the image the cloud thing
didn't match perfectly but you know this
is a demonstration with a live a live
manipulate in it because served by our
web server but if you want to you know
if you want to download it you've got a
big bucket to do that but if you want to
access it in the cloud you can hope
and what you see here these choices
download or open it the cloud is what
we're going to do for everything
people deploy as CDF for notebooks on
the web right so you know you can go to
it you can interact with it okay maybe
10 times 20 times we haven't quite
decided what that threshold is but for
that document for that user
at that point ok that's enough now you
got it downloaded or you've got to go
into your cloud account
that'll work you know that would be
pretty reasonable experience very much
well I don't quite know what the
distinction is you're making our cloud
does do tooltips
not quite so much I mean you know but
you know is it part of the dom right is
the purpose document object model or
webpage
no because so you know if you want
Google to find that tooltip on that
webpage where it's a badge that's
and yes if you're if you're like pulling
data like if the embedded object in that
web page is wanting to refresh itself
based on data that's changing somewhere
I think our time is basically up if
anybody has any other questions I have
cards here if you don't know how to get
in touch with me already I think most of
you do but anybody who wants them can
happen
[Applause]